sont très éloignés des salles de classe.
Ceux qui connaissent les qualités pour enseigner
et engager une audience
ne savent même pas ce qu'est un brevet d'enseignement.
Ils n'ont peut-être même pas les diplômes
pour être en quelconque mesure d'enseigner.
Je trouve cela triste.
C'est triste car les gens que j'ai décrits
étaient indifférents au processus d'apprentissage,
ils veulent être des enseignants efficaces, mais ils n'ont pas de modèles.
Je vais paraphraser Mark Twain.
Mark Twain dit que la bonne éducation
-- ou le bon enseignement --
est si puissant qu'il peut rendre bonnes les mauvaises mœurs,
il peut rendre puissantes des pratiques qui étaient affreuses,
il peut changer les hommes et les transformer en anges.
Les gens que j'ai décrits tout à l'heure
ont reçu la préparation adéquate à l'enseignement,
non pas d'une fac ou d'une université,
mais en vertu de leur présence dans les mêmes endroits que ceux qui engagent.
Devinez quels sont ces endroit ?
Les salons de coiffures,
les concerts de rap, et surtout,
les églises afro-américaines.
J'ai formulé cette idée appelée la pédagogie pentecôtiste.
Qui est déjà allé dans une église afro-américaine ?
Quelques-uns d'entre vous.
Si vous allez dans une église afro-américaine, le pasteur démarre
en réalisant qu'il doit engager son auditoire,
donc il démarre souvent au début avec une sorte de jeu de mots,
puis il fait une pause,
et il dit : « Oh mon Dieu, ils n'écoutent pas. »
Il dit : « Peut-on avoir un amen ? » Public : Amen.
Chris Emdin : Je peux avoir un amen ? Public : Amen.
CE : Et tout à coup, tout le monde est réveillé.
Le pasteur tape sur le pupitre pour capter l'attention.
Il baisse sa voix à un très faible volume
lorsqu'il veut que les gens l'entendent,
ce sont les habilités dont nous avons besoin
pour les éducateurs les plus engageants.
Pourquoi la formation à l'enseignement ne vous donne que des théories
et vous parle des normes et de toutes ces choses qui n'ont rien à voir
avec les compétences élémentaires, avec la magie nécessaire
pour engager une audience ou un élève ?
J'avance l'argument en faveur d'une refonte de la formation des enseignants.
On peut mettre l'accent sur le contenu, c'est bien,
on peut mettre l'accent sur les théories, c'est bien.
Mais le contenu et les théories
en l'absence de la magie de l'enseignement et de l'apprentissage
ne veulent rien dire.
Les gens disent : « La magie, c'est juste de la magie. »
Il y a des enseignants qui, malgré toutes leurs difficultés,
ont ces talents,
qui entrent dans ces écoles et qui impliquent leur audience,
et l'administrateur se dit :
« Il est si bon, j'aimerais que tous mes enseignants soient pareils. »
Pour essayer de décrire ce que c'est, ils disent juste : « Il a cette magie. »
Mais je suis là pour vous dire que la magie peut être enseignée.
La magie peut être enseignée.
Comment l'enseignez-vous ?
Vous l'enseignez en permettant aux gens
d'entrer dans ces endroits
où la magie s'opère.
Si vous voulez devenir éducateur en milieu urbain,
vous devez quitter l'enceinte de l'université
et aller dans la banlieue.
Vous devez aller au salon de coiffure,
à l'église afro-américaine,
et vous devez voir ces gens
qui ont le pouvoir d'engager,
et prenez des notes sur ce qu'ils font.
Dans la classe de formation des enseignants de mon université,
j'ai initié un projet où chaque étudiant qui arrive
doit regarder des concerts de rap.
Ils observent la façon dont le rappeur bouge
et parle avec ses mains.
Ils étudient sa manière de marcher fièrement sur scène.
Ils écoutent les métaphores et les analogies,
et ils apprennent ces petites choses qui,
s'ils s'entraînent suffisamment,
deviendront la clé de la magie.
Ils apprennent que si vous fixez un élève
en relevant juste votre sourcil d'un demi-centimètre,
il n'y a pas besoin de parler
parce qu'ils savent que ça veut dire que vous en attendez davantage.
Si nous pouvions transformer la formation des enseignants
pour apprendre aux enseignants
comment créer la magie,
alors pouf !
Les classes inanimées pourraient prendre vie,
nous pourrions raviver les imaginations, et changer l'éducation.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)